hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt ihr fällt heute bei teil 3 meine
skrill specials ich werde heute eine
aubergine püree machen oder einen
auberginen salat will man auch sagen
kann und zwar ist es ein grill rezept
weil ich die auberginen gleich auf dem
grill grillen werte aber ihr könnt es
natürlich auch einfach im backofen
machen
wir müssen nämlich jetzt gleich die zwei
maschinen die ich benutze auf dem grill
solange lassen bis das innere eben durch
ist und werden dann das innere
fruchtfleisch benutzen
führt dieses auberginen püree braucht
ihr außerdem noch etwas olivenöl 2
frühlingszwiebeln einen teelöffel salz
eine schalotte oder eine kleine zwiebel
3 oder 2 knoblauchzehen die habe ich
schon geschält und in meinem zweiten
teil des specials euch ein super
quicktipp gezeigt wie man knoblauchzehen
schälen kann dann brauche ich eine
zitrone und etwas pfeffer die maschinen
werde ich jetzt kurz vorbereiten und
zwar habe ich sie schon gewaschen
ich werde es einfach die auberginen hier
drauf geben
ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch in alufolie
wickeln und direkt mit zur glut geben
und die lasse ich jetzt hier so lange
bis ich eben die schale bis die schön an
gebräunt ist und gegrillt ist und dann
ist auch das innere richtig schön durch
die zwischenzeit werde ich jetzt
natürlich nutzen um eine zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen schon zu schneiden und
klein zu hacken und zwar möchte ich
jetzt die schalotten ganz fein würfeln
also richtig klein weder hier auch sehr
einfach drauf und taxi durch
knoblauchzehen genauso die halbiere ich
jetzt einmal oder dritte sie jetzt habe
ich in sekundenschnelle
richtig kleine mini würfel gezaubert so
sehen sie aus
da gebe ich jetzt einfach noch das salz
mit dazu und auch besitze drohne saft
bereit ist also schon so weit vor dass
gleich die auberginen dran kommen können
nämlich meine frühlingszwiebel und
nehmen wir einfach ein paar röllchen
später für die deko red die schneide ich
so in kleine dinge einfach ein paar für
obendrauf
es reicht schon und wird den rest sind
nehme ich wieder das schneidegerät
tausch aber den aufsatz aus weil ich das
jetzt nicht ganz so klein haben möchte
und die restlichen frühlingszwiebeln ich
einfach hier drauf und lass dir auch
kurz klein hacken
ich probiere jetzt auch einfach mal ich
habe das noch nie probiert
ich nehme es noch ein bisschen
petersilie mit hinzu habe ich vor allem
vergessen zu zeigen und ich probier mal
ob man die auch klein hacken kann ob das
auch geht nämlich meinhardt messer dazu
einfach nur wichtig dass jetzt einmal
kurz dran hebt zum fixieren und dann
einmal durch und fertig mit uns war ganz
schnell zu den auberginen bevor die
verbrennen zu sehen jetzt die auberginen
aus sind richtig schön weich und bevor
ich mir da jetzt die finger daran
verbrennen lasse ich sie einfach kurz
abkühlen nach in der zeit kurz ein
bisschen sauber und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder
jetzt nehme ich meine aubergine die ich
natürlich noch ein bisschen warm sind es
hier weg und das hier ist übrigens der
beste teil der aubergine den bitte nicht
wegschmeißen sondern den könnte einfach
mittelfuß und einfach aus essen drüber
pfeffer zitrone lecker so jetzt wird die
aubergine einfach mal öffnen
wie seht ihr schrecklich jetzt noch sehr
warm noch gleicht die andere auf mein
mann der mag eigentlich gar keine
auberginen der sagt immer dass ich für
ihn so ein gemüse das wird nie essen
aber dieses hier das liebte also
deswegen auch an alle die keine
auberginen mögen das rezept müsste echt
mal ausprobieren das ist super lecker
jetzt nehme ich das innere hier mit
einem löffel heraus gibt es in der
schüssel richtig schön vorsichtig
herauskratzen und durch das grillen
watch schmeckt die maschine auch richtig
schön rauchig also ich finde ich zwar
auch aus dem backofen gut aber dieses
getrennte aroma das ist wirklich
unvergleichbarer das so müsste das erst
mal ausprobieren das könnte auch super
auf dem grillplatz machen also einfach
alles mitnehmen vorher die sachen
vorbereiten zwiebeln und petersilie
alles in eine schüssel und dann einfach
noch die aubergine drillen reinschmeißen
und fertig so dass sieht zu nicht so
appetitlich aus es gebe ich zu aber
gleich wieder super aus einfach mit der
gabel bis nutzer drücken und dann geben
wir einfach diese frühlingszwiebeln und
die kettensäge dazu hier noch die
zwiebel und knoblauch und zitronensaft
und da gebe ich jetzt einfach noch so
eins bis zwei esslöffel olivenöl mit
rein schmeckt etwas treffer durch röhren
frühlingszwiebeln für die kleine oper
schiene aber es macht absolut bisschen
weniger frühlingszwiebel aus einer
reicht für zwei kleine auberginen
ich habe das immer so weil ich
eigentlich mal ganz dicke auberginen
habe aber dieses mal waren sie wirklich
ganz dünn
drei große 2000 verstehen oder drei
kleine vans super ich finde es auch so
richtig perfekt und füllt es jetzt
einfach nach oben
als einem geheimtipp von uns weiß noch
so ein bisschen schafskäse oder väter
mit hinein zu bröckeln
dann wäre es das ganze aber nicht mehr
vegan und es ist schon richtig veganes
gericht jetzt gebe ich hier noch meine
zurückgelegten zwiebel streifen oben
drauf die zwiebelringe die petersilie
und so habt ihr ganz schnell ein
leckeres auberginen püree gemacht oder
bzw euren auberginen salat
dieses rezept und andere rezepte gibt's
natürlich auf meinem blog auf der list
orten welt.de und ich würde mich
natürlich freuen
er mir eine bewertung geht und mein
video teilt wird es euch gefällt und
natürlich auch ob ihr dieses rezept
schon kannten und wie ihr das zubereitet
und ich wünsche euch einen guten appetit
bis bald ach ja und auf türkisch heißt
dieses gericht übrigens also diese oper
dieser auberginen salat künstler ein
mischpreis mit einer tasse ich wünsche
euch viel spaß dabei und guten appetit